even with you resolution no I feel like
if I make up my mind to do something I
just start then and then that doesn't
matter like I might not like our new
year I mean my brother talked about like
on the road I eat bad because I'm
excited be in the city and everyone you
ever wants to go here go here so we've
always been on like we go to those
places I told my brother we're getting
older we both got tighten it up on the
road so I mean he made a deal to tighten
up on the road and then my abs talking a
little bit of you yesterday some person
of I can't I don't want thought about
but just business-wise I need to tighten
up 2020 I'm so generous and friendly
that it's not that people take advantage
of me but I just yeah I'm kind of here I
do
you're very generous I'm very like I'm
very forgiving yes and then I have this
situation going on I don't marry you're
very well one things that you feel a lot
of people know about you is that you're
very you are very generous and probably
you know I consider myself that were you
might be recklessly generous sometimes
when there's nothing wrong with it
actually
this really isn't I don't mind that and
then you're you are very forgiving in
terms of like yeah and so are you so I
called you and hey am I being crazy like
excuse me and I I I told you I have to
make it but you know I call I say if I
said well you Rogan top film it if I say
that you're not crazy then you mean that
it's a function it's a problem but I was
tiger in the tall grass in that
situation you know without killing it up
yeah my name is Rosie that's kind I'm
just tighten things yeah yeah that makes
sense
that's right old time like I just won't
be an athlete may not be an [ __ ]
you've been a professional loosey-goosey
also here's the other thing some people
are worth a lot of effort some people
aren't and it's it's fine yeah that's
all that's I was doing her people's
feelings yes I'm like I just deal with
it
it's like I said I would try breaking up
with a girlfriend took me four years yes
my father said that one time he said he
had fired somebody in and I was like
cheese and he goes but there's somebody
who's waiting and who's been working too
hard and deserves it yeah you know a lot
more I like that about football like
watching hard knocks and stuff where
it's like this is football this is
professional football you want to play
in the NFL the reason that we go we play
there how about we take a sack
Magill is because he didn't fall for all
those pitfalls and it's rare it's
[ __ ] rare super maybe I'd fall in
those pitfalls I'm not saying I'm better
yeah but uh but but yeah you know that's
what happens we all know that we know
that what are we what I say to you
always talk about this if you're if
you're after something if you're after
something I'll be honest with yourself
you're probably not doing everything you
need to do because what does the world
do when you when you're not buttoned
down it's done it to me
so I'm speaking from experience he's
going they going Oh what see she's cool
next that's Olivia can you move by the
way that's awesome I'm sorry about that
can use some other way we got somebody
there are 50 people waiting in line if
you might if you don't mind 100% so it's
not how it goes I had this idea for a
business my buddies not report makes a
lot of money he looked at me he goes
don't do this I go why yours it's a
full-time job this is this is a rookie
talk right oh but I do I'm the positive
note resolution of sights firing
everybody not positive the other
positive not you guys know this you get
just kidding we fired you idea oh my god
oh we hide your sisters my college
family yeah but just don't say anything
John address a baguette the [ __ ] like
your sister you know she's great
Oh quick question though before we go to
the next one what is uh deadlift exactly
what is verses like a cleaner so the
bars on the ground you you bend down you
grab it and you lift it you're lifted
literally lifting up deadly yes peril
what are you doing what did I do
mm-hmm why chin why is that important
it's it's it's one of the one of the
best measures for how strong you are how
strong saving that so it's the best
thing you do for a full body
mmm what's a clean clean is this why
chin because I'm trying to understand
the difference okay okay
yep there's he and then a snatch is
overhead does what he did yeah that's a
clean and the snatches you go there but
overhead yep got
beautiful so I'm getting ready doing
this giant you got I'm on this casino
resort so what like you it's a big deal
to get on the casino tour like it's a
big deal so you know you gotta sell
tickets right - guns casino tour so I've
done Borgata which is huge and hard rock
which is huge
it's gone great so I'm in Oklahoma on
Saturday I did brick town on Friday
Oklahoma City drove to Tulsa Oklahoma
brain [ __ ] crazy rain so I'm there
for you know a Hard Rock Hotel Tulsa and
[ __ ] an hour before the show a
tornado warning it's right near there
I'm like I'm in my hotel room like the
[ __ ] is that the magic and hookers Papa
laughs cancel the show man what you hear
that tornado we don't get those in
December especially this close it ain't
good everybody's leaving it's a ghost
down there in the casino yo what I got
to do the show man here's that let's see
where we're at in half an hour like ah
dude I'm like because there's a line
yeah a lot of people he texts me I said
I went dude I'm doing this giant casino
it's 15 minutes for the show there's
eight people in there it seats like 1600
they're suppose to be near sell-out huge
and I tell the guy yo I can't go out
there do I go those eight people tell me
to come the green room I'll do a show
for her act ain't doing it out there
they're not gonna in the stage like
they've had like [ __ ] Kista they've
had like these huge because the stage is
so big yes I'm like just have them come
onstage on perform but don't leave in
the crowd now and I go listen dude is
there any way we can start half an hour
later you just can't do it because the
Native American rules we have to keep
time it's different like I'm sure you
can start linear and other clubs
we're on Native American land here we
can't start any later I go dude there's
eight people out there bro here's I
don't know what tell you man
do you want to cancel you know we can't
cancel let's give another 15 minutes see
yours okay well I can maybe push the 805
at 7:55 people came in she ASUS because
they didn't know once they found out it
was gone nah dude can't show it dude
yeah I want to die
my kids city I got snowed in tornadoes a
whole different thing snow just can't
show
I was I was scared I'm like alright I
want to leave I don't I don't want to
die it all hard-rocking new snow and if
that [ __ ] tornado hits hard rock I'm
gonna stop here gonna let no it's
terrible no everyone's scared man
it was cool though great show thank you
that's a good couch was like Himalayan
Buffalo two years ago there's a like a
blizzard I go oh I call Justin like oh
dude I'm in Buffalo there's a blizzard
man why the [ __ ] would you send me out
here in December cancel this shows use
million Buffalo dude so he was let me
talk to club owner I guess it's Buffalo
it's what we do dude people came to the
show lot shows [ __ ] snowmobiles they
come to more people come they party yeah
yeah it's fantastic O'Brien's in New
York and I was driving in there was a
snow blizzard up in the mountains and
it's been a long time since I've driven
it snows best man O'Brien was
slip-sliding all over the [ __ ] yes I
said pushing her a little bit I was
gonna be late
they just made my plane four minutes how
about I was driving Derek in a Sun from
oklahoma city of tulsa right we went to
the SUV and i don't know i just drive
man if the open highways know what
there's rain but whatever want to try it
SUV Jericho's can you slow down
I look to our family on 110 ton intent
that's too fast
papa side what wait what what you're
high
no we're gonna edit that out why okay
I'll keep you high nickel to you yeah oh
and they could talk yeah I don't know I
don't smoke weed dude I don't smoke weed
anymore I thought you're saying you're
hot no never
weird as I got my little man on Nintendo
switch cuz he played that target young
for Christmas and he loved it I'm like
really you're only given before like
Nintendo switch I'm like imma get him
one so I get on that and I get him the
kiddy games like the Ryan from YouTube
we could stay on the kid the Ryan from
you Cuba Sega take a fake Mario Kart
game and I got him a paw patrol game
they were super kitty I'm like God he's
only four oh he'll be four and fibia
like him nice
he's like and I'm like oh oh these are
too simple and Kitty for him so I go on
so he goes to bed I'm pissed I might
spend all this money on thing it's kid
don't [ __ ] like it so I get on there
it connects to the Internet you can
download games alright haha dude so Papa
Bear I'm like you know I'm like you know
I grew up with Mortal Kombat yeah so I
go on there I'm like he likes he why not
so every day I walk in the house we
wrestle Syria at home we're wrestling
that's just what he'd like to do is
wrestle awesome so soon so I'm like
maybe he'll like a fighting game might
be a little graphic for him and they
have more calm at 11:00 last time I
played was more combat - 20 years ago
dude so I download it and I'm like yo
let me just set it up for and put on the
easy mode I'm playing Mike holy [ __ ]
I play for for out I learn all the
fatalities and then the next morning I'm
like I'm just gonna try see what he
thinks so we're watching you girl hey
Bubba you want to try the you know try
your Nintendo again he's no pop I'm good
I go oh look there's actually a new game
on there look at this I'm showing me
that give me that and dude he's [ __ ]
it's it's addictive
it's a well he just he likes that how
hard it is for him to do it which is a
good sign but then it's more combat so
that its glory its court it's like am ia
terrible parent well I'm glad you
brought it so weird
my son my son I catch some plans tonight
for 3d and people are getting shot he's
eight they fall down blood seeps
everywhere now I'm like alright I don't
know I but then again I again I go wait
I came all you got to do is draw this is
next thing I know I'm playing I know
next thing I'm coaching I'm going no you
got it oh yeah old feet he's moving and
running right I go you know and you get
crazy ah didn't here's the problem my
son can I borrow your iPad he's been
skiing all day they're watching Mean
Girls
I'm like what do you want to do if you
want to play for tonight it's good if
you build it's like strategic other
people aren't I guess in roblox they big
these kid hands I'm like alright you
know even you've been physically active
good for eight hours again well my son
is a crafty little little so Mitch he's
eight
nice little he's craft I certainly got
[ __ ] well he was he doesn't know how
to do that
but on YouTube he was putting insects se
X in different forms then he put in
cantaloupes cuz he thought that's what
it's cantaloupes he heard somebody say
cantaloupes got some can't hold is he
he's eight yeah and his search history
is I was like hey bro it was all his
chicks like suckin their tits and huge
tits I'm like yeah all don't even be I
didn't go come here I go it's going on
but say your old man like scale no I go
if you're gonna use my iPad you can play
those games don't be going on YouTube
and looking up sexy guys why not very
good question I understand you're a boy
I get it all adult young right now like
I gotta help you through that stuff
that's all I said hey guys
whatever you sure like papa lights
cantaloupe ah so you're not gonna stop
at he's at home he's interested in yeah
I didn't want to shame him no you can't
cuz then it's like sex not like bad
negative thing now then he won't
daughter you know how embarrassing